[Music]
I'm here at signature at the roof to
celebrate my birthday party with all my
followers my team is busy prepping so
let's head inside and see what they're
up to
let's go I thought you'd be nice to
throw a little party so that I can
really get to know you
[Music]
Trisha is my makeup artist and her
boyfriend he does my hair if there's any
special occasion he's always Trisha and
a boyfriend
[Music]
hi I'm here at Joanna's party I'm all
the way from Philippines when I read the
Instagram post I'm just joking that
should I write this message to her on
suddenly oMG I receive message comment
from Joanna so and then I'm so Blanc
shocked Thank You joy for having me I'm
really really happy and thankful for
have for being young I'm sherry so we
are here to celebrate Joanna's birthdays
being selected to attend your party and
the best for me because I I can meet you
at last
we're here at Jenna's party today and a
food is really great it's really great
if I'm healthy but it's also really
yummy we really enjoy our time it was
really chill eggs we really enjoy
yourself and yeah all the girls our
daddy are really having fun the
atmosphere was exciting I mean since I
don't know most of them here I got to
know each and every one of them a lot of
friends that we have the same vision say
- oh great and the food and that provide
bye Jonah was one so great yeah the
ambience is amazing the food is good
yummy and healthy and delicious the
people here they are really really nice
we don't we don't know each other and
then like we started talking to each
other
and we got to click so quickly well open
the [ __ ] Allah is like the best gift
that we know I really really admire her
she really changed my soul my social
life and also my food habits I started
watching join us with your bank 2013 I
follow Jenna I think many years ago I
remember that time our journal was
studying in the UK I was each of every
every of the video zones so that time
Jonas was a chubby although I've been
following her YouTube seems I think it's
a first first video first year video I
actually saw some pictures of me
it was so bad it was really very bad I
was 72 kg basically I reduce my weight
to 49 from 72 to 49 yeah I've been
struggling with my weight for years I
just started to pay attention to
covering weight loss in tonight so what
i did was i rewatch all your videos on
how to prepare meal how to eat clean how
to detox and everything i'm proud to say
that since july until now i've lost nine
program but my journey is still long and
i'm trying to commit to your workout
routine you're my inspiration and you
motivates me a lot to please my way
don't think you do know you're gonna do
it you're amazing seriously okay keep
going okay promise me okay
[Music]
thank you so much for coming ladies
let's Cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you